all right
well hey everybody the lighting looks
really weird yeah weird life well
remember we changed it earlier yeah
because we were you were moving all the
RGB lights around so that's why there's
not one in the back anymore and that
one's different and all this other kind
of crap you know
don't worry about it
we're changing color now well yeah
because we had it doing some exciting
[__] for yeah when we were filming
earlier yep that's good Let it go you
know it's fine so yeah it's Sunday and
it's Mother's Day so happy Mother's Day
to any of you mothers out there I'm just
a cat mom but you know what I mean so uh
so yeah So today we're going to be
talking about as I uh hinted earlier Bad
Lieutenant because xanada sent us not
only Bad Lieutenant but also the
professional which is probably like the
next one that we're going to be doing
yeah but we actually uh you know had
some cocktails last night and watched
Bad Lieutenant
that's a good movie it is it's weird
it's actually a great movie well it's
Abel Ferreira so
um you know his movies are always kind
of like that this was actually the one
that he made after King of New York so
like King of New York with Christopher
Walken came out in 1990 and then this
one came out in 1992. and actually
Christopher Walken was supposed to be in
this one too he was supposed to be the
Bad Lieutenant uh but he backed out
about three weeks before they started
shooting it uh and April Ferreira was a
little put out about it I wonder why
um I think that he
I don't know I think it was a thing I
saw like a quote earlier like on another
thing about this where they were saying
that
um they think that Harvey Keitel like it
ended up working because Harvey Keitel
was not super jazzed about it either uh
The Story Goes that he got the script
and read a few pages of it and then
threw it in the garbage yeah
he'd like that but um but well he said
later on he's like it wasn't that bad
but he like he wrote he read some of it
and he's like there's no way I'm gonna
be in this [__] movie but then like
he kind of thought about it and then
he's like well you know how many chances
do I get to be like a lead and something
like this and and I have to say that
Harvey Keitel man he [__] went for it
in this it's one of the great uh just
letting it all hang out acting
performances let's call it that way
let's call it like that you know what I
mean where he just not I mean yeah he's
naked in it and stuff which is a very
famous scene but also just in the sense
of letting himself look like the biggest
[__] sleaze imaginable pretty much
and also just opening himself up and
being like just this um like this
emotional Devastation you know what I
mean yeah like and just like howling and
[__] like that so it is like a very very
brave performance I will say that I
think he did a good job he's great in
this yeah well the thing about it was
that I saw someone I can't remember what
the quote was but they when they were
talking about Christopher Walken and
they're like they weren't sure if
Christopher Walken would have been the
same in this because they said that
Christopher Walken was too quote unquote
elegant yeah um whereas Harvey Keitel is
not elegant yeah we were talking about
this last night we were watching the
movie because Tom said the thing about
Harvey Keitel is he's not a big dude no
um so you wouldn't think that he's super
like be super intimidating but there's
just something about him that's just
like really scary yeah I'm trying to
place his height based on his
environment and the people who are
around him and you know long shots where
you can see his feet touching the ground
I think he's my size about five six five
seven
and uh he took his clothes off for that
one scene though and um
he he shredded he he's uh I would say he
was up there with [__] um Charles
Bronson a lot of people don't realize
Charles Bronson was shredded too but he
doesn't look he doesn't look shredded or
intimidating and Suits or in clothings
you don't know you know
but uh he's definitely been on gear
works out
um when you see him with his clothes off
you're like yeah he probably could whip
your ass
and even like even if he didn't look
like that there's just something about
he's one of those actors I guess kind of
Oliver Reed was like this too and like
someone where they just feel like
they're just constantly teetering on the
edge of Madness and they just like you
they you feel like if you met them and
they and you pissed them off they would
just like tear your [__] head off
because there's like a little bit of
crazy [__] going on it's like he comes
across like that very much Kai Taylor
I'm sure he's a nice person in real life
it's probably fun yeah
guy telling this one he's uh
playing this cop
oh he's and dude's got no supervision
all right clearly
the other cops on the New York force
with him you know there are
gambling and doing [__] but they're not
they're not all that great those guys
you know what I mean they really don't
care about the crime that's happening
there's nothing they can really do about
it they just do their job investigating
and [__]
like you know they're
they find a car with some girls that
have been [__] Dome checked you know
both of them
Square yeah and [__] kaitel walks up
and looks at him he's just checking out
the tits on the one he's gonna look at
it they show that he's looking at her
too yeah the dead body which I was like
yeah and then keep it classy Harvey yeah
and then they go back
go back to talking to each other about
whether or not the Dodgers are going to
win this World Series yeah it's not I
think I don't think it's the World
Series I think it's like the lead up to
the World Series or something I don't
know anything about sports ball you know
what I mean yeah I don't really use it
either but they're sitting there he's
talking about how much money he's going
to win you know he says the Dodgers are
going to win it's a safe bet you know
and that's really the what the movie's
about he keeps falling deeper and deeper
into debt
because of these
bets
at the end he owes 120 000. yeah that's
right he basically owns it to the Mob
yeah he doesn't have the money they're
gonna kill him which they do and then
well yeah yeah and uh that's spoiler
alert
he knows all the hookers and all the
drug dealers and he's
given them evidence or they're giving
them drugs out of the evidence room and
having them yeah like he takes it from
crime scenes and stuff because you see
him doing that like one time like
they're they're like oh there's a key of
Coke in the car and he's just like oh
really I'm gonna go check that car out
yeah and then he shows up
you know the next then you see him he's
uh hanging out I guess his two call
girls and they've got having a threesome
going on and he's just getting high and
acting a fool really good
like he's losing his mind because he's
under a lot of pressure and [__]
he's got a family got kids but he
doesn't really seem to care too much
about him
I spent most of his time running around
with hookers and drug dealers and [__]
there's this real good looking heroin
dealer girl that he keeps visiting she's
played by the girl who I think helped
write this Zoey London she actually
wrote the screenplay for this and if
you've seen uh Ms 45 which is probably
one of able for errors like that that's
actually my favorite April forever movie
yeah um she plays the nun in that yeah
um sadly because there's a scene in this
and she's quite famous like as a
screenwriter and stuff and sort of you
know the hip New York uh kind of scene
of the 80s she was kind of big up on
that but um very Unapologetic heroin
addict uh she was pretty much uh you
know kind of one of those New York
artists where she's like yeah she had a
pair him what the [__] and like she
talked about it quite openly
um so there is a scene in the film where
she's mainlining heroin and that is
absolutely real she did actually do that
uh for the movie too and uh yeah because
Tom said yeah that looks real and I said
I'm imagining that Israel
the known heroin addicts and like I said
she was not ashamed of it she and it
actually ended up killing her uh in the
end she died in 1999 I think she was
only 37. yeah and she was uh gorgeous
she wasn't beautiful she was a beautiful
woman yeah she looked she looked she was
a model in real life she looks like a
supermodel actually better better
looking than a lot of supermodels me a
lot of supermodels was a plane she's
just super pretty
too skinny though I mean she's she's uh
she's very thin yeah but uh so the the
Bad Lieutenant is uh visiting her and
hanging out with her and buying heroin
from her and stuff and doing heroin with
her
I don't think they had sex though did
they no yeah
but he's having sex with the other ones
with the other hookers and um
he comes eventually he comes across this
case where this gorgeous nun gets raped
by two scumbags and they [__] the church
up and steal the Chalice
and they put a reward out for the
chalice and
Keitel he's Catholic but he thinks the
church is a racket though he doesn't
believe anything about it and then he's
like he's like why is the church putting
the church put a big uh reward out for
the Chalice they want the Chalice yeah
it's like 50 Grand or something yeah and
keitel's just kind of scoffing at it
he's like man chicks get raped all the
time in New York and the church is
sucking making a big deal over this type
of deal
and the other cops are like man you're
an [__] yeah and he's like well this
church is just a racket you know
well eventually which is true but he's
still an [__] yeah he's an [__]
well he goes to see the knot the nun
smoking hot young
which I've never seen that in personal
life most nuns well I mean well the
thing about it is like yeah you kind of
see nuns that are like these old like
crotchety old ladies but it's like they
were probably young at heart at some
point yeah like going to church bro I'm
sure like some young beautiful women
like like joined the not in my
experience well no but I'm just saying
there had to be at least one somewhere
sometime
not the Catholic church at least you
know [__] why would you want to do
that to yourself I mean you know it's
like everybody's got their own thing I
get it I'm not judging but I'm just
saying sure why would you subject yeah
every nun I knew was a mean old lesbian
actually one of them worked one of them
was an ex nuns who worked for a company
that I worked for and she was a top
seller man she was a [__] really good
sales person her and her wife I guess
she's just mean old lesbian
and then she talked bad about the church
too
a lot of people that have yeah yeah I
mean like I said it is they just kind of
outgrow it
um anyway
so he meets the nun
and uh tries they try to get details out
of the knot and she's not talking
even though she knows who did it she
knows the dudes names because well
Harvey Keitel who actually I didn't
realize this well I did kind of when I
was watching the movie but then like I
wanted to make sure when I checked like
afterward when I was researching but
yeah they never he doesn't have a name
they never name him like nobody ever
calls him everybody just calls him
Lieutenant so it's like he's never named
which is interesting and I'm pretty sure
that was a deliberate Choice like from a
maybe dehumanization standpoint I'm not
really sure but he um
so he goes and essentially like
overhears her confession you know to the
whoever like I'm not real up on like
Catholic terminology yeah the guy is
above her right so she's doing the
confession and he overhears her saying
that it's like yeah I knew who it was
like they just live around here and she
knew their names because they were kids
that came to that church or whatever and
but she's like but I'm not gonna tell
you who they are because she forgave
them yeah even though let's talk about
this because the rape scene in this is
pretty nasty and like a lot of that got
cut out for some releases uh in certain
countries and stuff which I can I can
see that but
um so so they not only like it's two
guys raped her but they also
um now the crucifix did they like just
rape like rape her with it like
vaginally or did they stick it up her
butt they just said vaginally for what
they said because I thought that okay
I've read somewhere else that somebody
said that she was sodomized maybe they
cut that part out but I'm not really
sure I'm pretty sure the the well we saw
Alexander sent us the the nice you know
uh Blu-ray of it and I'm pretty sure
that that's the uncut version okay
because I heard about now the cut
version had like five and a half minutes
cut out all right um they took out the
whole scene pretty much the whole scene
where he jerks off in front of the two
girls in the car yeah they took out
almost that entire scene
um some of the rapes see they left some
of it in but they trimmed some of it out
so it wouldn't seem so quote unquote
erotic
um you know because some people had a
problem with that so they took some of
that out they took out you know the part
where they were obviously really using
drugs
um so there was that but I think they
would like five minutes took out but all
of that stuff was in the version that
that Santa just sent us so that's
assuming okay I don't think they
mentioned any anal action no I'm just
saying I don't I don't know if just I
read that somewhere and I was just kind
of like well are they just you know
projecting or I don't really know but
yeah so
not giving up the information that
Keitel goes off and does some other [__]
he's gambling some more but he keeps
coming back to this case and keeps
[__] with him and he's like who are
you to forgive these guys they're going
to go out and do this to some other
woman other nuns and you know he had a
lot of good arguments you know about no
let me let me get him you know
you know and he just starts getting real
frustrated real Furious about it because
she's not giving up the information
and um
there's a scene after she basically
walks off from him I think in a church
right yeah because he's like he loses it
I forgive them and that's like the end
of it but the thing about it it's like I
don't I don't even think because of How
It Ends
I don't think he's
just at her he just can't believe it
yeah believe it yeah he can't believe
that someone would could forgive
something like that yeah and so the fact
that she's able to do that maybe makes
him think well maybe I can be redeemed
also even though I'm an actual piece of
[__] yeah I I don't know I had to I have
to see this several times I think that I
had to get my own interpretation exactly
what happened
she walks off from and leaves him in a
church and he's just [__] losing it
and he starts cursing God and [__] and
then he sees Jesus and he's like
standing but yeah and he sees him in
between the pews you know and he's going
you [__] what do you want
you better you got something to say to
me where the [__] were you yeah [__]
were you doing this where the [__] with
you it's pretty creepy like the way they
have that Jesus standing there is like
super creepy it creeps me out he's
crawling towards it you know he called
her you [__] you funny he's [__]
frustrated as [__] and um
and it
Jesus reaches down to like touch him or
something like that or he kisses his
feet he kisses his feet he's kissing his
feet Jesus reached out and touch him
like that and he snaps out of it it's a
black lady there in between the pews but
she's got the Chalice yeah the Chalice
that was missing she says yeah she says
yeah there's somebody like pawned this
at my yeah husband's pawn shop so he was
out of it [__] losing it and seeing
hallucinations but in a way it was like
a gift from God the Chalice came right
and it kind of leads down a path of
events that happened that
make you think it's kind of like a
a story of I don't salvation through
forgiveness basically but that's that's
exactly what it is yeah but that she but
you got to pay pennants which means you
have to die for your sins
yeah he did die for his sins at the end
I saw a review call this like a Passion
Play yeah that is essentially what this
is yeah he's like an evil Jesus or or
what and then I'd watch that movie
Evil Jesus and he will Jesus would have
been like Barabbas he might be like a
Barabbas character
a very very Catholic filmmaker a lot of
his pretty much all of his movies that I
know of have very very heavy Catholic
themes in Catholic imagery and this one
does steal yeah no it's probably not
Barabbas is probably Judas
because Judas was a betrayed was was a
traitor in in many of the stories
there's a bunch of different versions of
the Judas story there was a Gospel of
Judas it's not canonized but it's out
there
but he ends up dying anyway for his SIDS
so he might be like a Judas
he calls someone Judas does he the guy
remember when they're in the bar
um and the guy um I can't remember what
the guy's name is but the guy that
places all his bets like with the bookie
or whatever and he's talking to that guy
and the guy's just like look you know
you already are in the hole because he
keeps saying like he keeps losing each
game because he's betting on each game
and he's like no just double the bet on
the next one and that'll like pay it off
you know what I mean so he's just
getting like deeper and deeper in the
hole and the guy keeps telling us like
look it's like this dude is gonna
[__] kill you he's gonna blow up your
house like with your wife and kids in it
if you don't pay him off and so he says
stuff like that and then Harvey Keitel
calls him Judas at that point too so
like I said just like a lot of April
ferreira's other movies this one is very
this is really it's so weird because
this movie is like really religious like
I said it's like a Passion Play
essentially yeah but it's also like
super sleazy like you will need a shower
afterwards probably all of all of the
characters but most of the characters
not the nun but
all the characters are sacrilegious bad
people yeah they're just all scumbags
everyone's just scuba including the cops
they're all scuba yeah and well I mean
he's the worst but I mean you know but
that's the thing it's just kind of like
and the weird thing about it because
Tom's like watching this because I'd
seen it before like a long time ago I
might have seen this in the theater now
that I'm thinking about it but um
he's like this he's like this movie
doesn't really have a plot per se
it's more like a slice of life it's kind
of like a slice of life or like a
character study yeah but it kind of
reminds me of Taxi Driver is what it
reminds me of a little bit but it does a
plot does start forming out of there
it's just it's not real obvious at first
there's a couple things going on he's
fallen deeper into debt his time is
running out his his life is not gonna
[__] is not going well
um
he's done a lot of evil [__] all right
he's abused his own authority he's a
[__] scumbag yeah big time
he ends up I guess redeeming himself but
I find it questionable
he gets the he finally once he gets a
hold of the Chalice he's able to track
down the kids that did it yeah the
rapists yeah and he breaks into their
apartment
and gets hot and holds him at gunpoint
and then gets high with him yeah give
him some cracks yeah he's like hey you
want the good [__] and then they're like
yeah yeah
hand Customs together and wraps his
jacket around the handcuffs nobody can
see it and he basically kind of abducts
him in his car and the whole time he's
like threatening he's thinking about
killing him
but he's not and he doesn't he takes him
to the bus station
and on handcuffs him and says you get
the [__] out of here and he says a lot
of basically he's kind of glitching out
and he gives them
the money that he had thirty thousand
dollars thirty thousand dollars but it
was what he was originally gonna
pay for the BET in case you lost right
but he lost that many times so he got it
from a drug dealer got it from a drug
dealer right so he gives them the money
he's cursing them as he's doing it
gives them the money to basically start
a new life and to get it because he said
don't come back to New York your your
life is [__] here basically and they
were living in squalor yeah and they
were they were young I guess 20s
so they he he gets he allows them to
escape New York
yeah with thirty thousand dollars yeah
real conflicted about it you know and he
walks back to his car he's still kind of
cussing himself and cursing God and [__]
gets in the car and drives off and stops
at a light and so [__] another car
passes him and goes hey cop they shoot
him up and kill him it was over the over
the the the big gambling debt well yeah
because remember he discussed that he's
like well I'm gonna place that bet they
were supposed to meet the next day yeah
so I'm assuming that that's how the guy
knew who he was like yeah entertainment
knew his life was over right he knew
that he was going to be able to pay
the 120 000 yeah he seemed just very
resigned yeah like after because he's
sitting there with the two kids the two
rapists yeah you know holding them at
gunpoint smoking crack and they're
watching the game and so you know the
the Dodgers lose so he realizes now he's
120 000 in the hole yeah and he doesn't
get upset about it or anything he's just
very resigned he's like well that's the
end of that you know what I mean whereas
before he was like freaking out like he
was like the one game that he lost uh he
was listened to it in the car and he
like shot the [__] carpet
out and then tried to play it off he was
in downtown he was he's like what
Broadway yeah in downtown New York and
[__] he he put his siren on him
he's [__] crazy
yeah he's the nutcase in this he's crazy
but it's a great I mean good movie it's
a great character study like I said
you'll feel like really it's good
because after the movie was over so I
was like wow that was a downer yeah
miss it down for like for a Friday night
like I said you will definitely feel
like it's a very scuzzy movie like it's
very like I said Abel Ferreira like he's
kind of that gritty New York
all of like all of this was filmed
without permits um they just like showed
up and which I think he did all of the
films that way
um so when you see like reaction shots
of like people in the background that's
like absolutely real there's just like
real ass people just going about their
New York City business and here's the
Harvey Keitel shooting his car right
yeah so I've got some I guess because
they didn't have a permit to shoot that
scene I wondered if they'd be like what
the [__] is going on yeah
Old School New Yorkers they're just kind
of like whatever they're like yeah
that's how that [__] goes well the thing
about it is that
I love New Yorkers though yeah I love
them for that reason because they're
just laying out they're tough they're
not dealing with Boston I live there so
yeah I lived in Boston they used to go
to New York all the time there's a big
difference between the places I'd
probably take New York over especially
old New York New York right now in
Boston right now nah but [__] back in
the day back in those days that this was
filmed you know you could do more I'm
pretty sure that the crime that's kind
of at the center of this movie which is
like the the rape of the nun
that was kind of loosely based on a real
crime that happened in New York City in
1981 I think it was so they actually
kind of used that so I think they had
like the cop that was investigating that
like sort of Consulting on the movie
um interestingly the one scene where he
pulls over those two girls that are
teenagers yeah and uh you know they've
they're supposed to be teenagers yeah
they're supposed to be teenagers they're
underage they're supposed to be underage
and they've um you know they've been out
to a club and they have taken their
dad's car like without him knowing about
it they you know that's what Harvey
Keitel discovers and so obviously he's
gonna use this situation to his
Advantage but I'm it's interesting
because this scene doesn't go the way
you think it's gonna go because you
think that and the way that he's talking
you're just kind of like yeah he's gonna
make one of these girls blow him yeah
and then which it kind of seems like
it's gonna go that way like the way he's
talking because he's like you ever suck
a guy's [__] you ever suck a guy like
you start saying that and um so then
you're like oh [__] you know how this is
gonna go but it doesn't quite go that
way no
he just makes them simulate fellatio
makes that one simulate for the laser
white yeah like she has to stand there
like looking like an idiot and then
you're like with her mouth open like
that and then he's just like jerking it
like looking in the car and then the
other girl's on her knees turned around
backwards in the passenger seat they're
booty in the air so he can look at her
it's not as yeah the thing is I remember
seeing this when it came out you know
and I remembered it being a lot more
graphic than it really was you see it
again you can't really see that girl's
booty I remember seeing the booty yeah I
thought the booty in my mind was pressed
up against the window you could see
everything that's just that was a
Wishful thing that was just
I was Tom imagine the booty nice Brown
booty panties and [__] he pressed up
against that's how I remembered it no no
you can no you can barely see him you
can barely because you're looking inside
the car and you're mostly seeing things
from it's not you know it's not like um
the thing about his movies is that
they're really realistic they're very
grounded you know they don't have like a
lot of Artful shots or anything like
that they're filmed almost I don't want
to say like too much like documentary
style but almost like that because it's
like gorilla filmmaking you know what I
mean like I said he doesn't have any
permits or nothing so he's just kind of
uh filming stuff like catches catch can
kind of yeah this era of filmmaking you
know of course gone
uh you could probably have some people
doing stuff like this but not with
legendary actors I mean
[__] Harvey Harvey Keitel even though
he oh he probably wasn't a legend then
but the legend was being built in there
you know
I knew him from a movie that we watched
right after this called Saturn III yeah
which is a sci-fi horror which is one of
his first films he's quite young he's
great in it
even though it's not his voice they got
him dubbed but it sounds like him
it sounds like him anyway it kind of
does it kind of sounds like a more
refined version of it and we did a
review of Saturn 3 like a long time ago
but they dubbed his voice over because
they didn't want they thought it's like
Brooklyn accent was too distracting
didn't make a didn't make sense it
should have just left an accent like
that yeah I don't think anybody Earth
was supposed to be a [__] scum hole
anyway yeah so that's what I mean so it
probably would have just played into
that right into it yeah because I think
a lot of people have a lot of have a
misperception especially if they're not
from that right region but uh go back
and look at our review on that it was a
flawed movie
Saturn three
but it was kind of a masterpiece because
it was almost hit it parts of it were
very good quality like on par with like
I don't know almost kind of like alien
one which that's what it was competing
with had good acting for a fossil was in
it Michael Douglas
no Kirk Douglas yeah Kirk Douglas was in
it he did a great job and good great
sets running around naked yeah run
around yeah shitty shitty space scenes
which they subbed them out to another
there's a lot of turmoil on the set and
they were running out of money uh great
robot scenes and weird [__] it's kind
of like a Frankenstein story
Keitel played a
cool dude man a cool bad guy for [__]
psycho [__] incel social media
[__] cyborg
murdered a dude to get on the mission so
he could [__] get a fair faucet and
he had his job was to put the damn robot
together program it mind to mind
Bluetooth connection this is way ahead
of time for the 80s you know
but he failed a test so that he failed
the course and that robot came up
[__] psycho thinking that it was him
thinking that he it was carving cartel
well I had his brain tissue now in his
brain tissue it was like but it was
stealing thoughts from him right still
his personality from him
Richard Brown said Harvey was in Taxi
Driver oh yeah that's right I haven't
seen taxi driver in a long time
but this guy played the pimp that's
right yeah but this does kind of remind
me of yeah of Taxi Driver a little bit
this movie because like I said it's more
you know yeah there's a plot in the
sense of you know things happen because
of other things and there's like the you
know the rape of the nun and that that
investigation that kind of plays into it
and then like him losing all the money
like with the subsequent bets
um you know so that's kind of a through
line too but I kind of feel like a lot
of it is just like a study of him
because I was watching we were watching
the movie and I said this is like the
very definition of like a downward
spiral where he just kind of he just
staggers from one thing he's like you
know he's on the job it's like you know
there he goes to this one crime scene
where like these two dudes like stole
some money from like a grocer or
something like that and he basically
like shakes them down for the money like
he takes the money that they stole from
the yeah from the grocery store so like
he does that then he goes like and [__]
some hookers then he goes and like
shoots up some heroin and then he goes
and drinks a [__] ton I'm like how is
this dude still walking around holy
[__] [__] yeah what Constitution well
as soon as you got up in the morning he
snored a bunch of coke right
yeah right off his kids pictures yeah
that was super classy yeah well and the
thing about it too and I think I noticed
when we were watching this movie is that
at the end
when he takes like the two rapists and
they're in the car with him and there's
that whole discussion that mirrors the
like the same they're in the same
positions and stuff like that as his
kids were because remember like at the
very beginning of the movie he's
dropping his kids off at school and the
way that the kids are situated in the
coach you never really see the kids
again but um at least those two boys
he's got a bunch of other kids too it
looked like because there's a couple
other kids running around in the
apartment but the two boys like he drops
them off and the way they're positioned
in the car are exactly the same way that
the rapists are positioned at the end so
um so there's a lot like I said there's
a lot of thought put in this movie like
Zoe Lund she um wrote the screenplay the
original version of the screenplay I
heard was only 65 Pages which you know
if you know anything about screenplays
that means the movie would be about an
hour and five minutes but um Abel
Ferreira was kind of known for just kind
of taking the script and just doing
whatever with it like letting
um the actors improvise things and just
being like well what are we gonna do on
the day and [__] like that so he was
just kind of using that for suggestions
um the thing about it too is that
originally
Abel Ferrera instead he had intended
this movie to be more like a black
comedy I'm not really sure like to what
extent he meant that but he was like
when Christopher Walken was playing the
main character because like I said
Christopher Walken was in this up until
literally three weeks before they
started shooting and then he was like
nah I'm out
um but he's like you know the scene with
the two girls in the car like with the
jerking off and everything he's like
that was actually supposed to be funnier
and like it was supposed to end like
with Christopher Walken like dancing
with them in the street and like you
know they were wearing his hat and like
his gun belt and [__] like that I'm like
I'm not sure that would have worked to
be honest I mean I think it was the way
that the scene played out because they
said they kind of let Harvey just do it
like that oh and I'm not sure if this is
true or not but I read this somewhere
one of the women that was playing one of
the girls in the car yeah pretty sure
one of that she worked for Harvey Keitel
like as a nanny okay yeah and so they
asked him they're like is this going to
be weird because that's like your
babysitter right right he's like no no I
want to try something and I'm just like
all right if you've seen that scene I'm
just like now that makes it like super
weird but it's like I really like the
way I don't know I just I like the way
he played it it was really
real cringy it was tense and cringy
because you weren't really sure how it
was gonna go yeah and he was just being
so like creepy and like intimidating
you're like you just know this is gonna
go bad but you don't know exactly
standing out there in [__] New York
traffic the headlights going on when I
was out there jerking it beside this
damn car
looking into
any as a plain clothes policeman yeah it
was pretty [__] creepy that's what I
mean it's like can you imagine like if
you got traffic doing that [__] right
like cars going by
and like I said when we said that they
shot this movie without any permits or
anything like that so it's like those
are real life cars that he's just out
there like and the thing I don't know
like you can't really tell from the
scene I've heard again I don't know if
this is true or not but I've heard that
another take that they did of it like he
actually did like jerk off for real and
like you know
yeah finished all over the car that's
what I heard but I don't know I don't I
don't know exactly I don't know if
that's true or not yeah but I heard that
that was with his babysitter in there
I'm like maybe that's what he wanted to
try maybe they had something going on
can you can you imagine if you worked
that was like your employer and you were
both actors and then like you had to do
that scene it's like that would be so
[__] awkward the next day then you
had to go like watch this like watch
their kids she's like hey I just saw you
jerk off all over my face that's like
that's a little weird I don't know if
that's true but that's what I heard so I
don't really know I don't really know
um let's see grandther said I worked
with some low end types but never as bad
as the Bad Lieutenant well Jesus Christ
I hope not yeah this dude every single
Vice you can think of I mean he was an
alcoholic he was a drug addict he's went
to hookers he stole money
um he was like corrupt he was a gambling
addict it's just like he victimized the
[__] public yeah I mean he's a
criminal right so it's just kind of I
was like Jesus Christ is there anything
you haven't done that it's just
did he kill people uh did he kill
anybody in this movie
I didn't run no I don't remember I don't
think he killed anybody I mean like at
the end you thought that he was going to
kill the Raven because that's clearly
what he wanted to do like when he was
talking to the nun he was just like let
me get like let me
get revenge on them like he didn't
understand
I got it to reset oh it came back on I
just held both buttons down for a long
time
[__] having problems with that yeah
that's all star dog 78 said my favorite
Harvey Keitel character was Victor the
cleaner in point of no return man I
haven't seen that movie in a long time
that's another one we need to see man
we're like so behind
um crap there said in today's
environment the Bad Lieutenant would be
fired very quickly well I should hope
they should have fired him back then but
I kind of feel like the well the other
cops in this they don't like you're led
to assume that the other cops while not
as terrible as the Bad Lieutenant they
really don't seem to give that much of a
[__] especially the ones seen near the
beginning of the movie which like I said
those two girls get shot in the head and
they're just like in the car dead in the
middle of Union Square and there's
there's you know there's onlookers like
all around and there's all these cops
and it's just like they're looking and
they're going yeah that sucks or
whatever and then like I said Harvey
keizel is just like looking at her tits
but then like the other cops he just
walks over there and they just
immediately start talking about like the
baseball game and like what bet they're
gonna play so they don't give a [__] it
would just work they see that right but
I guess is what they were they're just
kind of hardened up to it right but
that's what I'm saying it's just they
didn't really seem to have and they knew
for sure that Harvey Keitel I mean he
was the one that was putting in all the
bats like with the bookie and stuff like
that so they knew for real that he was
at least into that I don't know if they
knew about like his alcoholism or his
drug use copious drug use or anything
like that but I just kind of feel like
they didn't really
I don't know because like I said he was
stealing drugs from crime scenes and
then kind of selling it to drug dealers
or then they were giving him a cut or
whatever because remember that one the
one scene where he goes to the crime
scene like I said and he's like oh
anybody looked in the car and they're
like no and one of his informants I'm
assuming it was also like a sex worker
and she's like oh I've heard there was a
key of cocaine in the car and he's like
oh okay I gotta check that car out so he
finds it and then he puts it in his
jacket but then like he's kind of
inebriated and so he gets out and it
falls out of his jacket and the cop sees
it the other cop sees it and he's just
like oh yeah like book that in evidence
but I'm pretty sure that other cop was
just like what was that doing to your
jacket [__] you know what I mean
so I kind of feel like the other cops
probably knew what he's obviously they
also knew he played it off I don't think
they really cared that much though
that's what I'm saying they didn't
really like they first that they kind of
did the same thing every now and then
right right
granther said that's why this movie
isn't that real in real life the vast
majority of cops would not turn a blind
eye to his [__] well I would hope I
would hope not because I mean this dude
was just a public menace
you know what I'm saying but I have to
say too like I kind of agree with you on
the on the deal with I get that The
Narrative of the movie is like his
passion place so it's like him
uh seeking forgiveness or learning to
forgive others and learning to forgive
himself I think was kind of what the
point of the story was
but I think
when he talks to the nun and he
basically like she says I forgive them
and that's like the end of it and he's
like what what right do you have to
forgive them because it's like what if
they go and do this to somebody else and
I kind of agree with him on that yeah
it's like I don't like because that
seems a little to me I'm not a Catholic
so I don't really know but I just to me
it seems a little self-centered yeah to
be like oh well I forgive them and like
that's fine which which you can do
that's cool but I don't think that that
means that they should be immune from
punishment because like I said they're
still running around loose on the street
they're gonna do it again and so by not
naming them you're kind of responsible
for letting them run around free and if
it happens to somebody else that's kind
of on you a little bit just saying so I
kind of feel like maybe that's I don't
know so that just seemed like a very
self-absorbed way of looking at things
like forgiveness perhaps yeah well
that's why I said he supposedly did
something that atoned right uh no those
dude I mean it was like I said this I
get it's it's a character study it's a
personal Journey for him like I said
learning to forgive he was but don't let
those [__] [__] just kind of
caught in a rock and a hard place in a
way because if you were if he were to
have rested them all right she wouldn't
have testified against him so right you
have to let him go so they would have
had to get lucky so you only had two
choices let him go or kill or kill him
that's why he was that's what he was
thinking about he almost killed him but
he let him go
yeah you can't let him go
yeah because like I said if they did if
they went and did that to somebody else
I'd feel really bad yeah
so you know what I mean so I I don't
know Grabbers that's why I should ever
be a cop I met a good soldier make a
good [__] special operative and [__]
like that I could never be a cop
I don't believe in the system
I believe in human Duty and action well
maybe that's like yeah that's like a
good way of putting it because like you
said if he had gone through the system
yeah like they because she wouldn't
testify even though she knew yeah they
were
um then they probably would have got off
anyway because they wouldn't have had
enough evidence yep so
so like you said he only had the choice
between those two things and he's like
well the old mate would have just like
shot him in the head and like not even
thought about it yeah I think that's
what the old but he originally was going
to do that right but then he thought
well I'm gonna try and be because like I
said I think that the nun the thing is
I think that's the good thing to do
though my interpretation of [__]
morals is a lot different than other
people the right thing to do is to [__]
could put those two put those two dogs
down that's the good thing the evil
thing to do is let him go
yeah they'll reoffend
I mean I would imagine and especially
something as egregious as that crime
that they had committed it would be
different if it was something that
wasn't that bad and I'm not gonna say
justice wouldn't be served because I'm
not arrogant enough to Believe In
Justice I believe in Vengeance I said
Vengeance was not served you know I'm
I'm not apologetic about how I think how
to [__] kill both those dudes
like I said not gonna lie I promise
[__]
[Laughter]
but um yeah so I don't know so that was
kind of one thing but like I said it's
not I mean the point of the movie was is
coming from a very Catholic place of
forgiveness and he's also learning to
forgive himself I guess because like you
said he knew that his days were numbered
essentially I think he knew deep down
that he was gonna get killed that day
right and so he thought what is what do
I want my last action on Earth to be do
I want it to be like just taking out
these [__] or do I want to
follow the example of the nun
and be the bigger person or turn the
other cheek or whatever so he wanted
that to be like the last thing that he
did and hope that it redeemed him I
guess did it we don't know
but Jesus didn't say anything when he
was standing there that was so [__]
creepy how did they like was that a
person was that a real person or was it
like a statue or I couldn't really tell
if Jesus yeah he's a real guy he moved
that was that's right he did kind of
like move his hands and stuff because
for a long time he was just standing
there really still and he was standing
like oh like a little bit crooked almost
like Jesus would be like when he was on
the cross but he was standing on the
ground so he was standing like kind of
crooked so it was really unsettling well
and then I'm sitting there looking at
going is that a person or is like a
statue like you couldn't really tell it
was right they had him in a religious
position like in a religious painting or
in a statue
that's why he was in that weird
you know what I mean yeah religious
icons are painted or that way yeah like
I said that's what was so unsettling to
me it almost didn't look like it's a
real person yeah
Oracle says she makes the point that she
can forgive them and still cooperate
with making sure they face the
consequences yeah see that's what she
should have done I think the problem I
had you know yeah it's all well and good
to like forgive them you could
personally you can forgive them if you
want to that's entirely up to you but
not cooperating with the police or like
naming them so they can face
consequences so they can be punished or
like be taken off the street so they
don't do it to someone else that's like
really irresponsible she wouldn't
testify basically she's saying that was
consensual so you could have never
gotten a conviction
yeah that's what I'm saying and like I
said they did like I mean and they
showed in the scene like the scene is
really uncomfortable to watch she said
it was her Duty as a Christian to be
like Christ and to suffer and that those
that those that those kids that those
guys they were like an agent of her
suffering yeah they were aging her
suffering that those guys were uh
innocent because they they were the
needy and just like the needy they're
rude and blah blah blah and it's just no
different than anything else she
rationalized it she did yeah but um yeah
there's like a long yeah she was wrong
okay just that's a very airy fairy
religious way of interpreting something
to make your ideology seem true that's
all it is
making your own ideology seem true
that's what most rationale is
to be honest the speech that she gave in
the confessional
where she was talking about the needy
yeah it came off as a little
arrogance that's what I was thinking too
yeah it was arrogant yeah which I
thought was kind of interesting she was
making herself seem very important
yeah and that this was an important
sacrifice but that's a lot of [__]
religious mumbo jumbo
your own religious sacrifice and that
your suffering is important
and that it that it validates what you
believe in
you know it's like I said it seems very
that seems very self-centered yeah and
then and then you know you're gonna take
it upon yourself and let these guys walk
free so they can victimize another woman
and then never pay for what they did
yeah
like I said I don't believe in Justice
per se but I believe in vengeance
I've just seen too many people [__]
just blown up or killed for nothing you
know and then people that deserve it not
get it no I don't like that I don't like
that at all
yeah I wasn't I wasn't but like I said I
think that was kind of the point though
yeah strong 78 said supposedly Zoe Lund
who like I said was the writer uh was a
victim of sexual assault when she was
real young yeah I heard that too uh so I
always felt the key to understanding the
movie was through the nun yeah and she I
mean she wrote a lot of those lines I
think she wrote a lot of her own lines
because she was in this too she played
like the you know the heroine uh you
know the heroin dealer or whatever but
um and she so she kind of wrote all of
that stuff and I'm not sure like I said
I'm not sure if she intended like the
nun to come off like that but that's how
she came off to me but like I said I'm
not Catholic um Starbucks said I am
Catholic but I agree with Tom and Jenny
yeah
[__] gotta pay
you know that's what that's really at
least so they don't make other people
suffer yeah I think that's the main
thing I guess you could say well the
Bible would say in some places that the
vengeance is mine you know the Lord not
yours in other words that the Lord meets
out the [__] punishment
but then they'll turn around and just
prescribe punishment for other people
for breaking rules and [__] so no in in
Christianity you should punish punish
people for the evil [__] that they do
yeah it clearly and like I said I don't
and we've talked about this before
because particularly in regards to
somebody like Carl panzram
um where I don't think that you should
put people in prison and like make them
suffer horribly as well
um just because that's gonna make them
worse particularly if you want to
release them back into society but I
don't think that you should let them run
like people like that run around free
either some people with other people
yeah and that that's the thing yeah just
keep them away from other people that's
all I'm saying any kind of aggravated
rape like that no you that they can't be
wrong yeah because I mean that was like
no that was that was bad yeah that was
bad like what they did to her they'll do
it again but that's what but it you know
in the context of the movie it had to be
bad because it had to like Shake Harvey
keitel's character out of his holy [__]
if somebody can forgive that then you
know maybe there's hope for me like you
know Redemption for me because look what
she forgave yeah that was like super
[__] up
but still like I said I just but you
know I like I said I'm not a Catholic I
wasn't raised Catholic and I understand
that like people that were raised
Catholic they have like a particular
thing and they have like a particular
mindset that because I've known some
that were like lapsed Catholics but a
lot of times that mindset that
um it never really goes away I feel like
completely
you know especially if you were raised
with it Richard Brown says the Old
Testament God was Vengeance yeah yeah
yeah basically and then if you if you
really look at the Covenant that uh
Yahweh yave
or uh El Shaddai depending on whatever
role he was in
at the time
the Covenant between him and Israel was
basically like a gangster's [__]
Covenant there was no choice I Choose
You you do this
if not I'd [__] Smite you you know
but
the original the original Hebrew God
is
a demiurge basically a devil God he is
the devil and God combined he's the
Creator and a destroyer
can reward and punish
did some weird [__] though
[__] killed Moses before I even
[__] find a promise land
just for not believing remember that
God's kind of yeah it got him out of
exercise got him out and got it took the
people out of Egypt and everything
it was just a very uh uh gangster God he
was more like a devil
in the Old Testament
and it's not just me saying that
[__]
the original early Christians from the
second second century and everything
um dear in in their original
canonized Bible
um it basically said that Jesus as God
was a new God and that the old God was a
was the devil basically
uh that was uh what was the
the book of marcion that was the
original New Testament but then the New
Testament that you have today and you
believed in was written as a direct
response to the book of marcion
that came out and [__] redeemed the
Old Testament God said oh no no no no
the old Jewish guy we're not throwing
that away he was good too we're going to
combine that
but this is the the the form of
Christianity that we inherited was the
one from New Testament I agree with book
of Marcio
more than or what we know of it it's
been purged out
but the descriptions of what was in the
book of marcion we pretty much know
and it said that
Yahweh
or El Shaddai which God almighty
her father of the Gods he was a demiurge
a devil God
Jesus says God was a [__] Universal
Cosmic God
and in the book of marcion there doesn't
Jesus was never anything I don't think
Jesus was anything that was ever born I
think he was a Celestial being
like Gabriel
start on 78 said Old Testament was the
Divine Justice God New Testament it was
Golden Rule God choose your Testament
Choose Your Own Adventure
it's a narrative man it's narrative yeah
American Military 100 says speaking of
movies with Catholic and religious
themes The Exorcist believer bombed at
the test test screening audiences booed
and was some walked out I wonder why I
haven't really heard anything about that
one
so I don't really know uh how that's
gonna go but I don't know I keep saying
like we're gonna see stuff when it comes
out but we haven't seen any new stuff
didn't you exercise well it was at test
screening so I'm not really sure like it
might still be in that stage that's uh
that's the the Pope's Exorcist no no
that's already out okay
no no this is a this is a new one okay
um but yeah this movie here uh getting
back to Bad Lieutenant yeah uh this I
think it premiered at can and pretty
universally loved I feel like um critics
were really into it like compared to
early Martin Scorsese
um I read actually Robert Roger Ebert's
review he [__] loved this movie and
he um he said what I was thinking about
it he's like Harvey Keitel is like you
don't usually see an actor of that
uh that's that famous or you know of
that caliber like just letting it all
hang out like that and so you really
kind of have to and like I said he
didn't want to do it at first like when
he first read the [__] he's just like
yeah no good acting I don't know if I
really but I mean I can't imagine
anybody else in that role now yeah I
can't imagine it good acting and you can
kinda
imagine you like sometimes you know you
can imagine yourself when you're in the
dumps you're like yeah it's kind of like
that guy you know I'm feeling like that
guy you know I could hopefully you never
have a day like this
he's [__] howling like a wolf I mean
I get that
[Laughter]
[Music]
making the faces yeah I was like man
worried about all that debt he's a crew
and many many times during the film I
was like man Harvey's having a rough
time yeah
and like many times too I was just kind
of like here he goes again like he's
just going from one thing to another
like he's at a club like doing shots and
then he's like snorting like bumps of
cocaine and he's like doing heroin I'm
like how is this guy still on his feet
holy [__] I don't like uh I just can't
even imagine how somebody could do all
that stuff and still be like walking
around and functioning and talking and
stuff like he was still you know he was
kind of out of it but not really like he
could still drive a car and [__] but I
was like man that dude's got he's
hardcore you know what I mean yeah but
uh seven o'clock let's go ahead and shut
this down Jim okay I got a bunch of [__]
we gotta do tonight yeah there is we do
and I still gotta transfer all the damn
files yeah all the [__] we shot today
all the [__] we shot today
um by the way if you didn't notice I
actually put up two count them two
videos today I put one over on my crime
and Memorial uh Channel which was about
uh Valerie Percy the murder case from
1966 unsolved and I also put up a movie
review on flickers of fear uh that was
tombs of the blind dead from 1972 the
Spanish cult horror film so if you
haven't seen those or you didn't notice
that I put those up then you know go
check them out because that would be
cool
I didn't know if anybody saw that I put
them up I just put them up not too long
ago so uh so yeah so everybody have a
happy Mother's Day out there what's
remains of it tomorrow is Monday so it's
gonna be haunting Mondays we're actually
going to be doing
um I think it's called back from the
grave that was the next one on the thing
because we're still doing season five so
I think it's season five episode seven
and I'm pretty sure it's called back
from the grave not Echoes from the grave
that's a different one this is back from
the grave so that's what we're gonna do
so if you want to watch it ahead of time
so you can play along with us on the
show tomorrow night then um you know
then go ahead and do that
um yeah American Military 100 said
Exorcist believer is a sequel to The
Exodus with Ellen burstin reprising her
role oh yeah I remember hearing about
that oh [__] okay well we'll have to see
how that goes then because I can't
believe that
that's right I heard they were doing
that with her in it but yeah so uh so
yeah so thank you everybody for dropping
by thank you xanada again for sending us
the movie we'll be doing the
professional too the next time we do a
movie review because we gotta watch that
as well uh so yeah we will see you guys
again tomorrow evening good night